so dr. Friedman how do independent
providers fit into the NHS one of the
kind of services that they provide well
good evening in an independent sector
providers provide services across the
board they provide community services
Hospital services NHS 111 services all
free at the point of delivery to NHS
patients and at the same standard that
other NHS providers deliver those
services last year 10 million NHS
patients were treated in independent
sector providers half a million surgical
interventions were done across 2,000
sites and that cost about 6.8 percent of
the total NHS budget that we saw just
before could the NHS function without
these independent providers well we add
capacity to the NHS and right from 1948
when the NHS began the NHS has worked as
a partnership of NHS own providers and
independent sector providers if we think
about dentists pharmacists hospices
they've always been there in the NHS and
certainly when the acute sector is under
as much pressure as it is now I think
it's unlikely that the NHS could provide
services to patients with waiting times
even as they are now without the support
of the independent sector now one of the
big complaints that we frequently hear
particularly from the unions and the
Labour Party is that these independent
providers are somehow in competition
with the NHS is that actually true no
it's not true we call ourselves the
partners network because we partner in
NHS providers the NHS just does not have
the capacity to deliver all of the work
that it needs to do in NHS owned
providers and so it has to deliver some
of that work in non NHS own providers in
the independent sector and it did we
take pressure off the sector we innovate
for the sector one of our members health
care at home has got a virtual ward
which its run for about 20 years now 419
acute NHS providers where patients can
phone up get advice 24 hours a day from
a healthcare professional which means
they don't have to go in
to hospital so we actually support the
NHS in a huge number of ways so why is
it you think in that case that you're
not in competition with the NHS the NHS
couldn't survive without some level of
independent provision why is it that the
healthcare unions have such a downer on
on independent provision well I can't
speak for the healthcare unions the
unions have their own views as I've said
the NHS has worked in partnership with
independent sector providers right from
its inception and if this is
privatization by stealth which I've
heard the union's claim it's a very long
process isn't it if by 60-odd years
after the NHS started we're still only
at six point eight percent of the budget
it's going to take several lifetimes if
it is privatization by stealth well
surely one of the problems is that
whilst government spending is roughly in
line with advanced country averages it's
the amount of spending by private
households on healthcare that's way
below the international average is that
something that we need to think about
more household stumping up more money
for themselves well I think that's a big
political issue isn't it that's
something that we as a country have to
debate and it's something that the
government or the opposition parties
have to think about I think what's
happening now is that the NHS is seeing
the effect of the demographic changes
the fact that doctors can provide more
and more treatments fortunately which
keep people alive longer and those
treatments are much more expensive so we
as a nation have to decide how we want
to spend our money all right how Freeman
appreciate you joining me thanks very
much my pleasure thank you in